Stop. How many hours did you waste today
pretending to be productive? We've been
lied to. Those morning routines, fancy
apps, color-coded calendars, they're
productivity theater, not actual work.
But what if five stupidly simple
principles could give you control back?
Principle one, the 2-minut rule. See a
task takes under 2 minutes? Do it now.
Your brain is running 50 browser tabs of
unfinished tasks. Close them. Principle
two, you don't have 24 equal hours. You
have maybe three peak hours. Stop
scheduling your hardest work during
zombie hours. Three priorities per day.
Not 30. Three. When everything's a
priority, nothing is. Your brain isn't a
hard drive. Write everything down. Free
your mental RAM. and Parkinson's law.
That project you think needs 4 hours,
give yourself 90 minutes. Watch your
brain find efficiency it didn't know
existed. Now, here's the truth. While
everyone else searches for the perfect
system, you could already be done. Five
principles. One week, your whole
approach transforms. So, what are you
waiting